[Musique]
mois de février 1984 monique la femme du
docteur martin ou disparaît en juillet
1984 on apprend que le docteur martino a
procédé à l'hibernation de sa femme dans
sa propriété et cela dans la perspective
de tenter l'expérience de sa réanimation
prévu aux environs des années 2030
le procédé de libération parce que
terminer sa vie et ses savants sont
vitales en mourir en un mot ou rémy
toujours ceux qui protestent que le
époque où l'eau ou la science certain
degré d'évolution
un an après la formation de ce qui fut
perçu comme un fait divers nous
pénétrons à l'intérieur du château de la
belle au bois dormant à la rencontre de
ses habitants
le docteur martin au vrai mais son fils
et là je demande
on va jusqu'où en bas de chez moi que
j'ai fait un
notre code cru au jeu pendant jusqu'à
cru bon le cas du docteur martin ou qui
constitue un devoir de vacances aux
autorités départementales ne se lève
plus de vagues assez favorable depuis un
an visiblement d'autres fantaisies en
matière d'enterrement ont suscité plus
de réprobation que le cadre du
professeur martinod en lieu l'on craint
que certaines familles influençable le
suive l'exemple du médecin angevin il ne
garde l'organisme dans très chère
puis c'est que j'avais exté le meuble
de froid la machine frigorifique il y a
fait 9 74 pour moi que j'avais et j'ai
été malade à l'époque bons sentiments
souvent souviens plus où c'est vrai que
c'est un bon monica disparu avant on
était comble entre nous que le premier
parti reviendrait l'autre bain donc
j'avais acquis le
le mahb le frigorifique
et puis quand elle est partie après
avoir utilisé les autres éditions
préfecture et tout d'historisation qu'il
faut je les mises dans la machine à
froid est un peu molle pour
pour obtenir toutes ses autorisations
m'a été donnée tout de suite ça se fait
très rarement mais ce classique mais à
moins classique c'est rare mais
néanmoins classique donc j'ai pu nous
dressions transport qui est classique ou
si je l' ai amené ici on mise dans le
dans la machine à froid ouais bon suivi
et ccct brut et parce que le mtq besoin
de glace carbonique pas de congélateur
et du gaz carbonique sinon je la perds
des irrémédiablement elle était
décomposée en azote hydrogène oxygène
était pourri gnac site était réversible
ça s'est su comment je n'ai pas envie de
remettre le sai csu à ce moment là par
tous les moyens audiovisuels je n'ai pas
envie d'en gagner
ouais bon elle saisit ses fonctions
vitales momentanément et elle attend
elle attend tranquillement
elle attend tranquillement avant cinq
ans à la grèce 1-2 ces molécules sont au
repos et les a toutes ces molécules elle
est jeune
la quarantaine donc les conditions
idéales pour une éventuelle
quand vous aimez quelqu'un vous fait ce
qu'il faut pour le garder
scientifiquement comme c'était il fit
n'est pas pour elle bien c'était entendu
entre nous le premier qui partait
s'occuper de l'autre enfin on en avait
parlé de cette visite elle pour faire
plaisir peut-être qu'elle l'a fait
qu'elle n'y croyait pas du tout mais ça
ne l'a pas dit mais jamais dit non
cependant et c'était une jolie fille
qu'elle rêve de revivre ses passes il a
toutefois sans même si ça lui déplaisait
tellement une production suisse des
châteaux dans son livre immaculé et
donc elle est là j'allais comme la reine
des neiges quoi les zones fière de son
mach 1 200 e
sont ici bien en glace et en attendant
de pouvoir émerger un jour si c'est
possible
ma tendresse pourra la faire émerger le
champ de sa blancheur de son livre de sa
glace il ya une pression et christian
dans ce sens qu'il nous faut pas que
processus de quoi ça n est qu en jeu
qu'ils ont ici il ya quelqu'un de
confiance qui vient vraiment ça me
demande toujours si sa compagne
appareils ont pas nous ou l'alimentation
de la cité qui va s'arrêter enfin il
faut multiplier les précautions
alors voici le consommateur principale
où je trouve monica moins 60 degrés
centigrades
températures très basses en personne qui
permet la conservation des tissus
biologiques
oui voilà il ne faut pas que courir cela
parce que quand on ouvre l'humidité
rentrée ça fait venir du vigan attendant
qu'il ne faut jamais ouvrir
je suis comme orphée veut pas brader la
regarder et c'est un gendarme qui m'a
au début il m'a dit mais pourquoi qu'il
ne faut pas il faut pas l'ouvrir il y en
a beaucoup des objets du lot si on a
beau être un des os et c'est curieux
parce que là elle voyage dans le temps
oui mais en tant que cellule reste
intacte enfin le bout du monde
hispanique ont pu être lésés par le
froid ça c'est une question
mais si c'est lui le reste intacte
partir de maintenant
pendant la tempête et indéfinie puisque
les règles sont très ralenti il ya cinq
ans dans un cimetière il y en a une ou
deux il y en a cinq
el roque monique repose dans dans une
enceinte à l'intérieur il ya ensuite
deuxième précaution les parois du meuble
le métal qui font qu'un centimètre
d'épaisseur troisième négociant mur j'ai
fait lever supplémentaires quatrième
précaution le mur de la crypte 5-1
précaution le mur du fond de terrain et
demi au fond un mec des pêcheurs allons
donc il ya une quintuple sécurité
superposés en plus de plus signer une
alarme sonore qui réveille les gens la
nuit dans un rayon de 2 km vit le jour
aussi et une alarme visuelle dans le
dans le château en permanence et sur le
perron pour les gens de l'extérieur et
une alarme visuelle ici ça fait donc
éventuellement un site où il y avait un
cataclysme
enfin une panne de kong 80 ans qui
devait voir de grand mère n'est jamais
arrivé si une telle éventualité arriver
on peut toujours demander de la glace
carbonique d'orgue un truc cours de
secours de secours de secours voulu ça
va mal votre actuel alors là les
autorités sont rassurés bon alors une
troisième chose
devenir parce que au cas où j'aurais les
ennuis définitif que je n'espère pas
complètement définitif d'ailleurs pour
le futur vous mariez part et on avait
parlé de problèmes de loger deux
personnes dans ce même immeuble
principal oui qu'est ce que vous en
pensez mais bien écouté au compte tenu
de ses dimensions
c'est possible parce que vous êtes
beaucoup à votre dame 1 et que d'après
les dimensions qu'on a
asus est très possible ouais on peut pas
mettre beaucoup plus de personnes mais
ça ne lui parlez que je ne sais pas
deux personnes se seraient cela oui
maintenant c'est mon fils en bas âge
avaient eu le dernier mot fan
heureusement cette fleur est dépassé et
vous pensez faire des expériences au
bout de combien d'années à il faudrait
faire découvrir temps en temps pour
faire d'ombré à nous voir le
comportement des tissus je pense que
c'est en 2030 que d'après der valk
opposition aux états unis et puis
d'autre que ne rêvez pas et c'est en
2030 on pourra avoir l'espoir pour volta
mot pour vous oui pour elle et puis pour
moi aussi subtile malheureusement c'est
ce qu'il faut retenir c'est qu'elle
revienne ce serait vous savez la science
progresse par sow à la bombe atomique et
demi en cinq ans les guérisons berthelot
dans cinq ans la lune est à cause de la
guerre bon et c'est venu en quinze ans
vous voyez il via des shows comme ça
faut avoir une bonne course sur une
confiance dans l'avenir
oui il faut avoir confiance je pense et
dans le froid et dans 3 c'est la seule
façon de voyager dans le temps dans le
temps
[Musique]